l'organisation mondiale de la santé
at-elle trop tardé pour tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé
le 11 mars 2020 l'om est qualifié pour
la première fois la situation sanitaire
de pandémie un an plus tard des
critiques émergent sur le temps mis par
l'institution pour alerter le monde au
début de la crise sanitaire
de hauts responsables se défendent et
pointe du doigt certains pays qui aurait
fait sourde oreille
sohail funk donc je pense que nous
devons nous demander si nous devons
peut-être crier plus fort mais peut-être
que certains ont besoin d'un appareil
auditif pas si nous faisons de notre
mieux pour informer chaque jour sur la
situation à former le monde sur ce que
l'on savait de ce virus sur les dangers
de ce virus et dire dès le départ qu'il
s'agissait d'un virus dangereux c'est
que les systèmes d'urgence sanitaire
devait être activée les premiers cas de
covile 19 ont été recensés en décembre
2019 à wuhan en chine
pour autant le 23 janvier 2020 l' oms ne
recommande et je cite aucune mesure
sanitaire particulière concernant les
voyageurs une semaine plus tard
l'institution décrète l' alerte mondiale
la propagation du virus s'accélère et
l'institution qualifie la situation de
pandémie si près d'un mois et demi plus
tard le 11 mars 2020 d'après joe louis
metz a évalué cette pandémie 24 heures
sur 24 et nous sommes profondément
préoccupés à la fois par les niveaux
alarmants de propagation et de gravité
ainsi que par les niveaux alarmants
d'inaction nous avons estimé que la
crise du coc u19 peut être caractérisé
comme une pandémie
vient ensuite la question des masques
jusqu'au 5 juin dernier lot et metz ne
recommandait pas le port du masque dans
l'espace public tout en laissant le soin
aux états d'évaluer leur situation et
les risques au cas par cas
c'est d'ailleurs sur la base de leur
absence de recommandations que la porte
parole du gouvernement s'ils battent
ndiaye se baser en avril 2020 je suis
les recommandations qui sont en vigueur
nous prendrons une décision pour
l'éventuelle extension du port du masque
dans toute la population dès lors que
nous pourrons la bâtir sur un consensus
cyan
syfy qu il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
consensus scientifique en la matière
cette crise sanitaire a également été
l'objet de tensions entre les états unis
et l'organisation mondiale de la santé
en juillet dernier si donald trump
claqué la porte de l'institution lui
reprochant d'avoir minimisé l'ampleur de
la pandémie
dès son élection en joe biden est quant
à lui revenu sur cette décision
un choix apprécié du côté de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
comme nous nous félicitons de
l'engagement du président biden à ne pas
se contenter seulement de réintégrer la
famille de l' oms a mais aussi à
travailler de manière constructive avec
le msc états membres et le système
multilatéral pour mettre fin à la
pandémie et relever les nombreux défis
sanitaires auxquels nous sommes
confrontés dans le monde avec l'ampleur
de cette crise sanitaire
l' oms pourrait commencer à se réformer
dans les mois à venir en janvier un
groupe d'experts indépendant appelé à
apporter des changements au sein de
l'institution